I I have
with them with a text that is my book
that I wrote with my son my elder son
I'm I'm a sort of economist and he's a
philosopher and we joined together in a
very a very harmonious collaboration to
produce how much is enough which how
much is enough the love of money and the
case for the good life and it is being
published in Dutch today I think so I'd
like to talk a bit I'd like to explain a
bit about the ideas of that book and
hope they will interest interest you now
the starting point of it was a little si
Keynes wrote John Maynard Keynes the
great economist wrote in 1930 called
economic possibilities for our
grandchildren 1930 and it was of the
depth of the Great Depression and what
Keynes is best known for of course is as
the inventor of depression economics but
in this essay he invited his readers to
take wing into the future and look
beyond the depression what what are the
what would be the prospects for
humankind a hundred years from now his
essay was written in defence this is an
important point of capitalism there not
in terms that most of its admirers would
have much appreciated
following Max Weber Keynes described
capitalism as a motivational system
rather than as a structure of production
relations and the motive on which it was
based was something he called love of
money love of money was useful indeed
crucial in getting humanity from poverty
to Plenty at the same time it was
despicable
moralists throughout the ages had
condemned it for center Gustin it was
the chief of the deadly sins and in
basing its social and economic system on
love of money Keynes argued that
humanity had made a Faustian bargain the
devil promised people untold riches but
at the cost of their immortal souls as
Christ himself had said it is easier for
a camel to go through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of heaven but pains like many
before and since 40 saw way out of the
trap
once the devil had made society rich we
could dispense with his services he was
no longer needed what is more the riches
he had created would enable humanity for
the first time to avoid God's curse to
Adam by the sweat of your face you shall
eat bread till you return to the ground
the return which Cain's promised was not
to the ground but to the Garden of Eden
where the fruits of the earth need only
to be picked and how is this to be he he
he had this wonderful idea he ended his
his little essay with this wonderful
flight of rhetoric which combined the
New Testament and Aristotle and he said
I see us free to return to some of the
most sure and certain principles of
religion and traditional virtue that
avarice is a vice that the exaction of
usury he liked the word usury is a
misdemeanor and the love of money is
detestable that those who were most
truly walk most truly in the paths of
virtue insane wisdom who are those who
take least thought for the morrow we
shall once more this is afterwards sent
the devil packing because we were rich
enough to dispense it with the services
we shall once more value n
above means and prefer the good to the
useful
we shall honor those who can teach us
how to pluck the hour and the day
virtuously and well the delightful
people who are capable of taking direct
enjoyment in things the lilies of the
field who toil neither do they spin
who'd neither toil nor do they spin so
that's how it ended but how could this
be
how could this come about well Keynes's
hypothesis was startlingly simple
extrapolating from existing rates of
capital accumulation and technical
progress he predicted that borrowing
large population increases in major Wars
living standards in the progressive part
of the world would be four to eight
times higher in a hundred years than
they were in 1930 when he wrote his
essay and that meant that the economic
problem would be solved humanity in the
developed countries would be able to
satisfy all their material needs at a
fraction of their existing work effort
ethic our effort hours of work had been
steadily falling since the mid 19th
century and Keynes extrapolated
extrapolated from that to say they would
go on falling steadily till we reached a
point and we're not far off that point
in in chronological time when we'd only
have to work three hours a day I ask you
invite you to turn to chart one which is
right at the beginning of the handout
and this was Keynes's prediction the
blue line is the rise in national income
per capita and the red line is hours of
work and you can see that you know you
get a five five percent even more
increase five times increase in GDP per
capita and the hours of work are falling
are falling to well under 20 and you
know eventually not
far ahead towards zero well why how did
he get this well he made he made a
simple linear extrapolation on hours of
work hours of work would continue to
fall at the same rate as they had in the
50 years or so up to 1930 in fact they
did continue to fool though at a slower
rate in the post-war period but towards
the end of the last century something
odd happened hours of work started to
stabilize at levels far above 15 hours a
week so what's the explanation of
Keynes's mistake well one obvious one
and I want to highlight it straightaway
and I come back to it later was he
believed that human needs were limited
and given steady progress in technology
or productivity would therefore be
progressively satisfied with less and
less work effort so I want to consider
some explanations and I group them under
three heads the three WS I call them
work welfare and wants like all
classical economists Keynes thought of
work as a cost incurred to get a bundle
of goods in technical terms it was a
disutility the sacrifice of time and
effort to get what one wanted but
perhaps in today's world work shouldn't
be treated as a cost but as a benefit so
that's one possible explanation and in
our book we call this explanation for
the failure of hours worked for the joys
of work now let's look at explanations
connected with welfare what's happened
to welfare our habit is to measure the
growth of welfare by the growth of GDP
per capita that's what we normally do
but this is simply GDP per capita is
simply the mean average of income one
cannot say what is happening to welfare
until one knows how income is
distributed now Keynes another I'm
criticizing this great economist and you
know it said it was only a 12 page essay
he couldn't deal with every single
objection to what he was saying and you
know that's later academics to sort of
point to all the holes in the argument
and I'm doing that at the moment he
failed to distinguish between needs and
wants
he used the two terms interchangeably
and he took the reasonable view that
needs were limited because they were
absolute the relative character warrants
forces up consumption beyond needs and
to consume more and more people need to
work longer hours than they really need
to in order to satisfy their needs now
sociologically minded economists have
distinguish between different forms of
consumption lust let's call it
consumption lust lust most famous is
Thorstein Veblen conspicuous consumption
consumption designed to show superior
status always a very very important
important motive for consumption
throughout history great palaces great
you know great cathedrals anything any
in any any any any monuments which the
rich have erected and in fact we're
grateful to many that many of them
exists were designed to show conspicuous
consumption they were designed to
display the the fame of the Builder and
the fact that the builder had a lot of
money then there is a snowball
consumption which is very important
especially in the modern world
consumption designed to show superior
taste then there is bandwagon or envy
consumption wanting things because
others have
very strong in children and that's where
a lot of it starts ecause some parents
indulging sure he's got something why
can't I have that you know that that
kind of that kind of envy consumption
and snob and envy Goods are not mutually
exclusive many good snob Goods mutate
into bandwagon Goods leading to their
abandonment by true snobs soon as
something gets too popular the truth
snob moves somewhere else and finally
there's a oligarchic consumption which
was identified by economists Roy Herod
and Fred Hirsch the argument is that
there's only a limited number of top
goods like places at elite universities
so competition for them intensifies as
the general social condition improves
and it is characteristic of position
goods positional goods that they
deteriorate the more people have them we
say that the purpose or end of human
striving should be the good life for all
and we identify seven basic goods which
we believe constitute the good life let
me let's just turn to the next chart the
penultimate one which is the basic goods
thank you health security respect
personality harmony with nature
friendship and leisure
so we now comes to the question how much
is enough the answer is enough to lead a
good life individual preferences will
determine the ranking of these goods in
our own minds but enough of them all
must be present for a person to be said
to be leading a good life that's our
argument now my last point and I'm
coming rapidly to an end I'm sorry I'd
gone on to say
the last chart policies for realizing
the basic goods limitations on hours of
work to which I've added in my own text
work sharing basic citizen's income a
progressive consumption tax and curbs on
advertising would such a reorientation
of policy we ask require the support of
religion possibly the basic goods as we
present them and not logically dependent
on any religious doctrine but their
realization is probably impossible
without the authority and inspiration
that only religion can provide most of
the liberal reformers of the 19th and
20th century were Christians others
among them others among those who as
Keynes said of himself were those who
destroyed Christianity but but but but
but yet had its benefits
so lapsed Christians but still part of a
certain way of thinking about the world
could a society entirely devoid of the
religious impulse stir itself to pursue
the good life and that's the question of
which we end the book thank you and
thank you very much